Hello world. It's a Raj and
hold on. Hello Sir Roger.
My name is Nora and I really
need your help. What do you need?
I don't have time to explain.
They're coming after me.
Can you please just press the
number four. How are you? Hello.
Hello. Number four. Okay,
whoa. Where am I? What is this place?
Put your hand where we can see though.
Hey, over here, getting
the car. Wait, who are you?
Just giving him the order to
perform a brain drain on you.
Okay.
I definitely don't want a brand.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Okay.
That was close. Wait a second.
You're just a kid.
How do you know how to drive around here?
Kids are better drivers. The novels.
I can take video games. All right,
well what is this place and why do you
need my help? This world is Cold Cola.
It's similar to earth,
but not really.
I asked a friend to teleport you here
because I need your help finding a
legendary device called the Luma.
Wait, so I'm on an alien planet.
Yeah. Dope. All right, so what's the Luma?
It's a device that can power the entire
planet with unlimited free, clean energy.
It would save our entire planet from
the destruction caused the pollution.
It's location is on this USB stick.
But I need your help finding the
relevant information inside of the stick.
The King of Cola,
King Nana once the stick because he wants
to use its power for himself to create
a giant Burger and it's only he can eat
instead of powering the entire world.
Oh, let that happen. We got to
find it before he does. Okay.
I definitely don't want you your
planet to be destroyed.
So let's do this. Alright,
so I'll just plug this USB stick
in my laptop and there we go.
Wait,
this is just a bunch of pictures of
your planet like mountains and rocks and
lakes. Exactly. I got, this
picture's from a satellite.
One of these pictures has the Luma on it.
It's a bright pink.
We've got to find which
picture has the Luma,
but it would take me years to find it.
There is 5 million pictures on this USB
stick and that's why I need your help.
You understand computers. So maybe you
could show me how to do this. All right,
I can help. Let me see. Do
you know what programming is?
I've heard about it, but I don't know
much about it. All right. Check this out.
So a computer is a machine and we can
use it to do literally anything we can
dream up. And the way we can do this,
he's by a process called programming.
You can also call it coding
or software engineering.
Basically it's a set of instructions
that we give a computer to do some task.
That task can be creating a game world
like Super Mario or playing a list of
songs or even creating a website.
That sounds awesome. So how
do I program something? Well,
you need to choose a programming
language first. Dakota. Okay,
whoa. Computers read instructions
as a set of ones and Zeros.
These are instructions that are
easy for a computer to read,
but they're kind of hard for us to read.
So we can use programming languages like
c or Java or python that are made up of
words instead of numbers. That way we can
read them and understand how they work.
If we take a language like python,
we can write a simple program
that just says hello world.
All I do is type the command print.
Then the phrase hello world
into this python text editor.
Then I hit the run button and it will
say hello world and the outlook window,
that's the output of the program.
See to us the program just
said print hello world.
But under the hood all this text
is broken down into ones and Zeros.
So a computer can read it and
process it and that's awesome.
So I guess my thing is the
best programming language,
well it's definitely my favorite one.
I thought it was a really easy language
to start learning programming with.
But in the end programming is an art form.
It's something you can get better at.
With practice,
it's the art of problem solving.
I really like python because you don't
have to think too much about what the
right commands to use them and instead
you can just focus on solving your
problem. That's great. Cool.
I'll learn to use fights in that.
So how do we use fighting to find the
new nine? All this pictures? Well,
we're going to have to do some
machine learning using iPhone.
What's the machine learning?
Well,
the traditional way to do programming
was to tell a computer what to do.
Like give me the exact instructions.
Let's say we want to tell her that
to text the Luma in a picture.
Well we can write code that can detect
all the different features of what the
Luma looks like.
Like it's color and shape and size,
but the Luma could be in many different
kinds of positions in one of these
photos. There's no guarantee of
what exactly it will look like.
You do have some pictures of Aluma right?
Definitely there on the computer as well.
Okay,
so instead of us telling the
computer what a little looks like,
we can have it learn what the Luma looks
like. That's called machine learning.
It's when we give a computer, not a
set of instructions to complete a task,
but instead a set of data and the task
and have it learn from that data to
complete the task. So we can use python
to create a machine learning model.
Then we'll feed our model a
bunch of pictures of the Luma.
Our model will learn exactly
what the Lumo looks like.
Then once it's learned
what a Luma looks like,
we can give it all the satellite pictures
you have and they will tell us when it
detects the Luma. Awesome. So how
do we make a machine learning model?
Well, there are lots of different
machine learning models we could use,
but a really one I like to use
is called a neural network.
A neural network can learn anything if
we give it enough data and computing
power. Here's how it works. If we
have some data with two columns,
the first column is a set of picture is
a little among the second column is a
label that says Aluma or not.
Blooma.
We can feed in each row of the data
to the neural network one at a time.
There was some pattern here,
some kind of relationship between the
two columns and I neural network can
figure it out.
Once it's learned this pattern,
we can give it a new picture and it'll
automatically be able to tell us if there
is a luma or there isn't.
How does he do that? Well,
the neural network is actually
just a few math operations.
Our input is going to be an image,
but if you think about it,
an image is really just a set of numbers.
It's a set of pixels and each pixel has
a value that corresponds to a color.
A computer reads these pixels so it
can display the colors of the image,
so it's a table of numbers and our
neural network is this series of math
operations.
It consists of a set of layers.
Let's just use a simple network
with three layers on input layer,
a hint layer and an output
layer in a neural network.
Data goes from the input layer through
the hidden layer to the output layer.
When it reaches the output layer in how
puts a prediction of what it thinks it
seeds, what connects. Each of
these layers are a set of weights.
Each weight is a matrix and
since we have three layers,
we have two weights between each layer.
What's the Matrix? Please don't tell me.
Movie would smell emotion. What you
watch Hollywood movies on this planet.
All right,
nevermind.
A matrix is a math word for a group
of numbers that has a set of rows and
columns just like our pictures.
We will multiply are input by our first
weight matrix and that don't give us a
new set of numbers.
Then we take those numbers and feed them
to what's called an activation function.
The activation function will output a
new set of numbers and that's our hidden
layer. We'll take those numbers
and repeat the process again,
using the new numbers is inputs,
input times, weight activity,
just like that,
and it produces our output of prediction
value that says what percent the neural
network thinks it's
Aluma or not. Wait, wait,
what's an activation function?
It's a math formula that makes sure our
neural network can learn any kind of
relationship.
There are two kinds of relationships,
linear ones and nonlinear ones.
That means if we were to graph the
relationship between any two things,
the line would be either straight
or squiggly, an activation function.
Make sure our no network can learn
both kinds of relationships, but yeah,
we can add as many layers as
we want to our neural network.
We can also try to modify our neural
network to do all sorts of mathematical
operations.
That's a lot to take in.
Let's just use a simple narrow
network for now. Agreed.
We can code this neural network in python
really easily and just a few lines of
code. Each line represents a type of
layer that the neural network is using.
Each of these keywords is a different
math operation that the network is using.
The process of learning that it network
uses is called training. We create,
our neural network has just two major
seats and a number numbers that each of
these major cs starts off as random.
We're going to input our luma images
into the network. One at a time.
We'll do this 60,000 times.
It's called training.
We do our input times wait,
operation then activate the results.
We'll do that twice to hit our prediction.
Then you calculate how far off our
prediction was from reality and use that
change to update both of our neural
network whites ever so slightly.
We just keep doing that
over and over again.
And eventually those random numbers we
started off with in our neural network
started to get really useful. So when we
give our network a new image of Aluma,
it will know exactly whether
or not it's a luma or not.
I said monkeys there. Here we go to find
the PNEUMA hello to his don't training.
Did you just say blasted
monkeys? Yeah. All right. Uh,
it just finish. Okay, let me give it
the salary pictures. They found it.
It's in this picture. Awesome.
I've go the coordinates.
Let's tell it for days.
Yes. Thanks rob. Anytime. Good luck.
We need one of those on earth too.
Speaking of earth,
can you tell important he
back now? Sure thing. Bye.
See Ya. All right. It's good to be back.
There are three things to remember
from this video was there.
It's the traditional way of programming
is to give a computer some instructions
on what to do.
Machine learning is a form of programming
where instead of instructions,
we give a computer some data and a goal,
and then the computer learns how
to do the goal using the data.
And a neural network is a machine learning
model that can learn from data and it
consists of matrix operations,
input times. Wait, activate,
and there were two kinds of relationships.
Two data points can have
linear and nonlinear ones.
That means a straight
line or a squiggly line.
Neural networks can learn both types.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and I hope you have a happy new year.
Thanks for watching.